c'est pour quel type d'opération que
vous êtes déplacés ben vous paie une
facture et une facture parce que bon
bain étaient fermées donc payer une
facture de désincruster et combien de
temps est-ce que vous avez attendu là ce
matin au plus d'une heure un défi pour
la post parvenir à organiser un service
minimum sur la durée avec tout juste un
quart de ses effectifs et des conditions
parfois difficiles ici aux terres
sainville pas plus d'un client ne sera
acceptée par guichet et d'ici la fin de
la semaine tous les bureaux mobilisé
deux vont être équipés d'écrans de
protection en plexiglas
notre priorité aujourd'hui reste la
sécurité de l'ensemble de nos postiers
première premier message que je voudrais
passer à la population martiniquaise
c'est de vraiment venir dans les bureaux
de poste qu'on cas d'impérieuse
nécessité aujourd'hui c'est de respecter
à tout prix les distances de sécurité
d'un mètre à un mètre cinquante
ça c'est quelque chose de primordial
c'est des messages que nous passons au
quotidien avec nous nous postiers
ensuite de venir dans nos bureaux de
poste lorsque ils n'ont pas le choix
mais de venir avec un stylo leur propre
stylo pour éviter de se relever que le
virus se propage éventuellement
désormais sur 45 bureaux 13 seront
ouverts dans 12 communes dans le nord
caraïbe et le centre st-pierre
schoelcher fort-de-france à joseph et
lamentin dans le sud du cos rivière
salée et rivière pilote et sur la côte
atlantique
lefrançois trinité sainte marie et basse
pointe pendant le confinement
aucun bureau ne sera jamais ouvert le
samedi ni l'après midi la plupart des
bureaux mobilisés vont ouvrir cinq jours
dans la semaine du lundi au vendredi de
8h à 12h
seul fort de france ouvrira plusieurs
bureaux aux terres sainville et
s'intéresse en commune plusieurs
exceptions à noter à sa joseph quatre
jours seulement d'ouverture le bureau
sera en effet fermé les mercredis et à
trinité et du causse seuls trois jours
d'ouverture seront possibles il s'agit
des lundis mercredis et vendredis
pendant toute la durée de confinement
seuls quelques opérations seront
possibles comme les retraits et dépôts
d'argent retirer du courrier
après avis du facteur mais aucun
affrontement ne sera possible aux
guichets et lettres seront pré
affranchie sur borne est l'e.coli
devront obligatoirement être pré
affranchie chez soi grâce à internet
aujourd'hui nous n'avons pas la
possibilité de donner de dire à nos
clients vous pouvez à franchir un colis
en contact avec le cliché parce que ça
nécessite trop de proximité donc
aujourd'hui pour pour un martinique et
qui a besoin d'envoyer un colis
c'est de l'affranchissement ligne c'est
tout à fait possible ou alors d'acheter
un colis prépayées dans les bureaux de
poste qui nécessite pas de pas de
contact direct avec le guichet équipes
pré affranchi par définition dans toute
l'île votre facteur ne passera désormais
que trois jours par semaine les mercredi
jeudi et vendredi
ces missions ne seront guère différente
et livrer vos lettres colis et même vous
recommander mais attention aucun
rapprochement n'est autorisée avec les
clients ils peuvent se mettre d'accord
avec le client qu'ils rencontrent leur
tournée pour le poser que le colis à un
endroit pour que le client puisse le
respect de le récupérer lorsque ce colis
là ne rentre pas par exemple dans la
boîte aux lettres donc aujourd'hui on
fait vraiment confiance à l'intelligence
locales et aux facteurs qui aujourd'hui
connaît extrêmement bien ses clients et
qui aujourd'hui est en capacité délivré
sans se mettre en risque
enfin l'accueil spécifique des
professionnels en carré pro se met en
place dans huit communes
il sera assuré dans les centres courrier
un numéro d'appel le 36 34 sera dédié
aux entreprises pour ces dernières le
maintien des envois et de la
distribution est en effet vital